so this is going to be a quick
PostScript to our use of the factor
theorem before the factor theorem is
that special version of the remainder
theorem where if you've got a polynomial
you sort of want to usually start with
someone it's you know you usually start
off factorize so if this was your
starting point we want to find out what
what am I supposed to divide by so I can
turn this cubic into a quadratic and
then off I go so what do we do like what
does using the factor theorem look like
if this was your starting point what's
the first thing you're going to write
you will start to sub in values right I
would probably write tests and then I
would start to throw some numbers at
this until a particular number that I
tried gives me what gives me zero what
that means is because this is also the
remainder theorem right what that means
is the remainder for that particular
factor the remainder is zero that means
it's a factor and I can divide through
by that great okay now you're gonna have
a look and see this guy here because you
know where this came from this is going
to take you some time to get to isn't it
right because I suggested that you start
close to the origin because that's easy
numbers 1 negative 1 to negative 2 it's
gonna take you to get until 3 until one
of these actually divides through it
because X plus 1 and X minus 1 X plus 2
X minus 2 not none of them will divide
through okay but what I want you to pay
careful attention to is this number here
the 90 because it actually gives you a
clue so you don't have to completely
randomly guess okay have a look at where
the 90 came from look at where the 90
came from the 19 necessarily comes from
where there's only a single combination
numbers that gives you the 90 which one
is it it's the constant terms isn't it
the three the five and the six or the
negative 3 and the 5 and the negative
six okay so because the constant term
comes from those numbers and they're
kind of the numbers you're trying to
guess right except negative what you can
do is you can be a bit smarter about it
and look at this 90 and say oh I think I
can go more immediately to a factor
by looking for the factors that go into
90 right so 90 when you are divided up
we can divide this up can't wait to find
the factors of 90 and what would you
like me to divide by two and 45 will do
and then what five and nine maybe after
that three and three okay so now I've
got the prime factorization to 5/3
squared
okay so any combination of those is
going to be up here you can actually see
where the two the 5 to 3 and the 3 come
from do you see them right there's the 3
there's the 5 there's the 2 and the
other three that go into there okay
so in fact it's not that bad of a guess
to go if you if you so wanted to go
straight to 5 or negative 5 that's not
that bad I guess even though 5 negative
5 they're not normally what you would go
through they're quite large numbers but
the fact that there's a 90 there is kind
of like a bit of a ring bell like it's
got to come in there somewhere
right if it weren't 5 it might be say 10
right that would also go in but I'm less
likely to have 10 because I've got to
have 3 factors in here right if it were
10 then I would need a 3 and a 3 those
would be my other numbers and I'm less
likely to have them even though I Drive
one okay so therefore you can use that
to not just randomly guess not just
randomly guys so maybe underneath what
you've written here right
you'd say when locating the first factor
because that's what we're doing if you
use this until you throw it until you
get one right when they cane the first
factor okay test values test now use
that our divisors of the constant term
I'll say that again when you're looking
for that first fact I'm throwing numbers
in substituting until you get 0 the
values if you try out the values you
should lean towards our divisors of the
constant term
now it's worth pointing out I mean my
initial advice is still true because one
negative one
they're always divisors aren't they does
that make sense but I mean I suppose it
could have been one and 90 or negative 1
and negative 90 so yours pretty much
you're still going to test close in to
begin with but suppose you test one and
you test negative one and then you're
like oh no more options right then you
don't just keep on testing Rayleigh for
instance if I gave you some other
polynomial and it was like X cubed minus
don't don't actually do this cuz I'm
just making up numbers plus X and then
you saw a minus 21 on the end there okay
do you see that if I tested one a
negative one and neither of them worked
I am NOT going to test two and negative
two does that make sense because you're
like that would never have I would have
gone straight to three and negative
three or even seven and negative seven
does that make sense so you don't have
to do it completely randomly some trial
and error is still required but I'm not
a hundred percent okay so have a look at
this guy what are you going to try you
could do - - and - they're good chances
or - four and four you'd skip - three
and three wouldn't you because that's
never going to give you anything useful
okay but you'll still start at one in
fact let's just quickly give this a go
because I know not everyone was here we
did this one is kind of your default
where you start and you will frequently
like disproportionately frequently get
one as I am a zero what am I going to
get one plus one minus 9 plus 11
takeaway for what is it I think it is
zero isn't it because it looks like my
positives add up to 13 and my negatives
add up to negative 13 so this is zero
which means what what's my conclusion
from that X minus 1 is my factor that I
can divide through by okay so let's just
quickly do that let's rehearse it the
more times we do this the more we'll get
into our heads I'll do the long way
rather than synthetic for now so are
there any terms any X terms which have
no coefficient or zero coefficient
they're all there right four three two
one
zero everything looks fine okay you tell
me what to write what's the first
divisor X cubes very good that leaves me
with X to the four minus X cubed yep
I'm going to do my subtraction now so on
the next line I get I'm subtracting and
it's a negative so it's 2x cubed isn't
it
bring down the x squared term and then I
ask the question again how many times
has X going in plus 2x squared oh good I
multiply back 2x cubed minus 2x squared
watch for all those negatives when I do
the subtraction
negative 7x squared bring down the X
term how many times am I going in yep
notice 7 X multiply back negative 7
squared plus 7x double negative there
yep subtract 4x very good and this is a
relief isn't it finally we get this
point which is like oh yes that is what
I was expecting because I'm going to put
a plus 4 up here which gives me the 4 X
minus 4 I'm supposed to get so thumbs up
it was indeed a fact I didn't go crazy
so now I know that um the original
polynomial can be written in a new form
I can write it as X minus 1 because
that's what I divided by x the what's
its called again their question very
good
like sir okay now because this is a core
tech this guy over here I I have to go
again don't know I've got a I've got to
keep on throwing things against the wall
to try and get a factor out of this and
then you would proceed you would reduce
the thing to a quadratic that's left
over and then you can factorize that on
your own make sense